shanell with a definite maritime feel in
hamburg
the annual Machado show is for many the
final highlight on the annual fashion
calendar for Karl Lagerfeld it was very
much a personal highlight this year for
the first time he showcased his designs
for Chanel in Hamburg which is the city
where he was born
Lagerfeld turned the entire auditorium
of the Elbphilharmonie concert hall into
a catwalk beautiful relaxed balanced
exquisite music great seats great room I
was impressed by how the individual
elements were linked so beautifully and
smoothly detail was bursting with
emotion it was very very powerful it was
all charged somehow all wrapped up in
the story of Karl Lagerfeld you could
really see and feel that it wasn't
sentimental but very emotional
Hollywood stars Kirsten Stewart and
Tilda Swinton as well as model Lily Rose
Depp were among the invited guests and
of course well-heeled customers came
from all over the world this year the
2100 guests were transported back in
time to the 1930s and life at the
Hamburg port on stage sailors and modern
mariners decked in the Hamburg city
colors
[Music]
we are in Hamburg and I know he's been
looking for a way of coming to Hamburg
for years and finally he found it with
this with this building and so it's a
very happy it's like a homecoming but
also I think it's not a nostalgic moment
for him it's an opportunity to introduce
people to his beloved birthplace the
Elbphilharmonie Concert Hall is fast
becoming hamburg's most famous landmark
it opened at the start of the year and
it was built on the foundations of an
old warehouse directly in the harbor
area karl lagerfeld is believed to have
been born in 1933 in his early 20s he
went to Paris where he worked for
various fashion labels he became one of
the world's most successful designers
and joined Chanel in 1983 since then the
traditional fashion house has seen a
return to its glory days
the Matador collection has been key in
that development produced annually since
2002 each year it's unveiled in a
different City in 2011 it was Mumbai in
2013 Chanel went to Dallas
[Music]
and in 2015 it was the turn of Rome the
focus is always on craftsmanship every
individual piece is produced by small
Paris studios who do the work by hand
business these Studios had a tough time
because work done by hand is not prized
anymore
and it's only thanks to Lagerfeld and
Chanel but they still exist she now
bought them all up and now gives them a
lot of freedom and that's really special
because it doesn't need to go to that
decline Atelier so that's the kind of
luxury and craftsmanship that Chanel
stands for the love of detail and
craftsmanship is put down to Karl
Lagerfeld now believed to be 84 years
old he apparently still designs the
entire collection himself that's unusual
in the fashion industry
[Music]
he's a great example to us all in being
unstoppable and he's so young in his
attitude to life I think that's one
thing we can really all kind of learn
from him and take forward he's just he's
just never never says no on he goes you
know he's already talking about the year
after next the material in hamburg's
Elbphilharmonie concert hall
I'm coming to Hamburg Karl Lagerfeld has
come full circle but the fashion King
did not stay long he left without a word
rushing off to focus on his next
collection
you